there is growing confusion tonight over
whether president biden feels the
situation along the southern border
is actually a crisis he used that word
saturday for the first time in public
talking about the border but his top
spokeswoman seemed to contradict that
today
white house correspondent kristen fisher
shows us tonight
after weeks of administration officials
describing the situation at the border
as nothing more than challenging
challenges we are
challenged at the border over the
weekend the president himself described
it as a crisis
when explaining why it's taking so long
to raise the refugee cap
the problem was that the refugees were
working on
kevin's up
is that now the official white house
position that there is indeed a crisis
at the border the president does not
feel
that children coming to our border
seeking refuge from violence economic
hardships and other
dire circumstances is a crisis he does
feel
that the crisis in central america the
dire circumstances
that many are fleeing from that he that
that is a situation we need to spend our
time our effort on as the white house
downplays the president's use of the
word crisis
his predecessor is calling it a horrible
situation
there's never been anything like what's
happened at our border
and people are coming in by the tens of
thousands they're walking in they
we had all he had to do is leave it
alone on friday it appeared the white
house was leaving alone the cap on
refugees
that was put in place by the trump
administration only to walk it back
a few hours later after enormous
pushback from democrats on capitol hill
from senator dick durbin to
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
this has anything to do with the
pushback from democrats
on capitol hill i don't think you've
articulated what our change in policy is
so
go ahead john don't do that well
well you can see the white house press
secretary never really answered
the question there gensake insists this
was all a misunderstanding noting that
the initial order included a caveat
to raise the cap past 15 000 refugees
once that limit
had been reached though gensake also
conceded that the president's
initial promise of raising the refugee
cap to more than
62 thousand now seems unlikely
brett kristen fisher on the north lawn
kristen thanks